there's been a lot of conversation and
debate around bitcoin and inflation is
it a hedge how should it perform in a
high inflation environment and are
markets forward looking or not natalie
brunell was recently on a fox news
special around inflation and she had
some really interesting thoughts as to
why people should be turning to bitcoin
looking at it learning about it and
understanding an asset that cannot be
debased away here's natalie's comments
on bitcoin and inflation you believe the
entire world would be using crypto even
if it's limited to certain projects i
think the entire world will be using
bitcoin why because we need a superior
form of money would there be enough
bitcoin out there to you know to make it
a viable backbone for the entire
financial global financial system well
that's exactly the point because you
know what bitcoin is immune to inflation
and we need a form of money a superior
form of money that's immune to that
because who benefits from inflation the
rich people the people who have assets
and the people at the bottom really
suffer and we've never had this bad of
wealth concentration since the late
1920s and money doesn't really trickle
down but the defaults will trickle up
and i think everyone in this room can
agree that at some point that money
printer will go bur again it has to it's
just math we're too far into debt and
when it does the bubble will get even
bigger the wealth concentration will get
even worse and thank goodness we have a
parallel system through technology that
we can peacefully exit into and start
accumulating bitcoin to fix some of
these problems and leave behind
demonetize the fed's monopoly on money
as we continue to live in a perplexing
interesting and kind of chaotic world
one thing is certain there will only
ever be 21 million bitcoin you can't
create more of them as we continue to
see loose monetary policy and
undisciplined fiscal policy become
pervasive around the world bitcoin is
the signal among the noise it continues
to simply follow the programmatic
monetary policy and produce block after
block after block of transactions no
matter if inflation is high or low no
matter if demand is high or low
bitcoin is unresponsive to changing
market dynamics the world has to change
the bitcoin that's the way that money
should be that's the way money is going
to be most likely moving forward hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time